samedi soir saint jérôme un partisan
tente d'intimider le défenseur jonathan
diaby
ils le traitent de poules mouillées y
compare ses cheveux à une main une
serpillière quand finalement le
spectateur à savoir un avertissement
mais aucun partisan ne reçoit
d'avertissement et l'animosité dégénère
on insulte raciste bien une et
commentera ce sont des avoirs - la
famille bon vieux [ __ ] babouins et
rubis gens ne trouvent pas mon problème
c'est fait même et flatter les cheveux à
certains points comme si c'était un
alien notre une jeune le point de non
retour survient quand des partisans
entoure et invectives sa famille
le noir c'est mon par minute et déjà
qu'ils sont en train d'y retourner chez
eux on voit m'asseoir aussi ma copine
chez ma femme j'ai commencé à verser des
larmes parce que ça avait juste plus de
bon sens mais comme moi je peux
apprendre voir ce qu'encore aujourd'hui
c'est un passé déjà c'est juste
déplorable
après avoir avisé son capitaine jonathan
diaby décide finalement de quitter
l'aréna avec sa famille en tant que
commissaire de la ligue dans l'amérique
en dehors à qui je tiens à m'excuser et
jonathan diaby et aux membres de sa
famille les propos racistes sexistes
homophobes sont tout à fait
inacceptables et intolérables les
commentaires racistes homophobes et de
toujours leur place sur les réseaux
sociaux
les appuis aux joueurs déferle depuis
samedi c'est inacceptable
des gestes qui sont regrettables qui
sont l'âme à ce jeu là absolument
dégueulasse mais certains estiment que
les équipes doivent assumer leurs
responsabilités
4 le mans avec local c'est la
responsabilité la sécurité de la rien
forcer sa seconde avant de basculer dans
un match si pourriez on s'excuse pour ce
qui s'est passé mais ferment les
propriétaires disent aussi vouloir
renforcer la sécurité
identifier les partisans qui ont été
agressés ce qu'ils ont tenu des propos
racistes pour les exclure des matches à
l'avenir ici julie marceau radio canada
montréal